[Music]
do you know
what you're putting on your skin
makeup can highlight your best features
smooth out imperfections
and help you feel confident and
sometimes you're just too tired to wash
it off before you go to bed
you could get away with this for one
night without causing too much damage
but what if one night turns into
two then three then four
and then 100 days go by
and you still haven't taken your makeup
off
what would you look like would you have
a
face full of acne and
could makeup cause cancer
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you wore 100 layers of makeup
your skin is your body's largest organ
it protects you from the environment
keeps you warm and
allows you to feel the world around you
through temperature and
touch but we
are making it hard for our skin and our
bodies to stay healthy
the average woman puts around 515
different chemicals on her skin every
day
what could all these chemicals be doing
to your body
while your skin acts as a shield
it's also permeable all the things you
put
onto your body can soak through your
skin and
into your bloodstream parabens
and formaldehyde are two notorious
chemicals that
are often used as preservatives you may
see parabens
on ingredient lists in makeup
moisturizers
hair care products shaving creams and
gels
they caused a huge stir in 2004
when scientists discovered them in
samples of breast cancer
but there's been no scientific evidence
that
parabens cause cancer scientific studies
have shown that
the body breaks down and excretes
parabens
concluding that they're safe to use in
cosmetics
formaldehyde is a different story
since this preservative is known to
cause cancer
but companies have set maximum safe
limits
to keep their products cancer free
so if the chemicals aren't an issue why
would it be
a bad idea to leave your makeup on for
100 days
well first off you'd be fighting an
endless breakout
all those layers of makeup would trap
the dead skin cells which
create the outer layer of your skin
called the stratum
corneum dead skin cells are what clog
your pores and
allow acne causing bacteria to grow so
your pores would become bigger and
deeper
to cover up this bad breakout you'd be
tempted to put on even more makeup but
that would only make the issue worse
and every day your skin is exposed
to unstable atoms called free radicals
these seep into the middle layer of your
skin
the dermis and break down collagen
this leads to wrinkles makeup
can accelerate this aging process by
trapping those free radicals
so your skin would start breaking out
and becoming wrinkled
but that's not all your skin would get
drier each day due to inflammation
and it's beginning to flake to make
matters worse
your skin wouldn't be able to absorb
products correctly
acne and wrinkle fighting creams
wouldn't work
i'm sorry but your complexion is not
looking so
great maybe you should try
a new skincare regime try washing your
face
twice a day with a gentle cleanser and
follow it up with some moisturizer
oh and use sunscreen if you're going
outside
luckily your skin can recover if you
treat it well
you might not be able to get rid of your
new
wrinkles completely but they'd become
less noticeable as your skin regenerates
by the way even if you don't wear makeup
you should still use this skin care
routine
you'll look young and healthy longer if
you wash away the free radicals
chemicals and dead skin cells that
accumulate
every day and if
not washing your face for 100 days has
consequences
what would happen if you didn't clean
your entire body
well i wouldn't want to be around you
for one
but that's a story for another
what if
you